do you still want me to help with this
thing we've been talking about you got
damn right I do and when it's all done
you all be more square with me you have
my word when I finish watching the first
episode of stranger things I knew
exactly how I'd be spending the next 10
hours of my life I mean I had to keep
watching and whether it's Game of
Thrones or Gilmore Girls that urge to
binge watch is a compulsion many if not
most of us have experienced it's also
exactly how I felt during the opening
hours of mafia threes heavily
narrative-driven campaign unlike many
sandbox shooters mafia 3 takes great
pains to introduce its major players and
flesh out their motivations rather than
rush you through some hackneyed set up
so you can skip straight to the
carjacking and cover-based shooting the
narrative takes its time lingering on
scenes that make all the action that
comes afterwards feel far more
meaningful ah well I about setting up a
tax enter key to running a successful
black bag operation is plausible
deniability is why I stole all this [ __ ]
from the FBI certain players will
undoubtedly recoil when confronted with
the harsh shameful realities of
America's past especially since Mafia
doesn't sugarcoat any of it well ain't
gonna bow and scrape to know just to
sell a little dope but the setting is
handled definitely and it genuinely adds
to the story being told the historical
context colors the events and informs
certain aspects of the characters though
the campaign's primary focus remains
squarely on protagonist Lincoln Clay's
deeply personal quest for revenge this
is a one way road lincoln and once you
start down it
ain't no turnin back unfortunately I was
less impressed with mafia threes
gameplay which is mostly unremarkable at
least during the games very earliest
portions as with most third-person
open-world games much of the action
consists of running shooting and driving
at first I found Lincoln's basic
movements to be relatively clunky and
precise similarly I found the aiming
slow and unresponsive even when I
attempted to increase the analog stick
sensitivity I developed a better feel
for both over time but many of the
mechanics remained disappointingly
simplistic enemies for example generally
stand in place or pace on short
predictable loops outside of combat and
in combat they generally grab cover and
stay put periodically popping up to fire
off a few shots I only noticed enemies
flanking on a handful of occasions
ultimately the action I've experienced
so far has been fine unoriginal and
imperfect but functional nonetheless
over the course of those first several
hours the campaign opened up very
gradually adding and expanding gameplay
options at a relatively slow pace once I
gather better weapons and recruit more
associates unlocking the political side
of Lincoln's power grab I'm hoping mafia
threes gameplay will develop complexity
strong enough to match its already
stellar story and there's plenty of time
for that to happen I've only played
roughly six hours of a game that will in
all likelihood span dozens of hours I
still need to explore the expansive city
of New Bordeaux and determine if it
holds anything of interest beyond story
missions I still need to dismantle more
rackets and dig deeper into the strategy
underlying the campaign and I still need
to find out if Lincoln story can
maintain the same caliber of excellence
it achieved out of the gate be sure to
check back next week for my full review
but when Lincoln clay went after the mob
he inflicted more damage in all the wars
and hurricanes come
[Music]
[Music]